Spit out the misty shinobi and let your body understand, finger,
that person is a barrier for public affairs
[Applause]
Yeah, yeah, you can't see anything from the outside
We can't get it, so we're going to be
served
by us.
We've got 10 people, so we can't do it like daytime Let's
attack the year
[Applause] My
home is a car
Ahhhhhhh Go
up and get organized
Blue Moon What are you
doing?  Don't sweat, survey
ca 1 piece
As usual, that
person seems to be in a slump
.  Even though it's
fine, look at that time new
Ursui Kagura
I'll teach you something good This guy changes his personality when he wields a sword This machine
was sunk in the sea during the academy days It was
n't before the data logger It's a
lie  No,
after all, this is the 4th generation Mizukage Magna of the Yagura.